i'm very curious
there was talk for a while of amazon
doing a tv series based on galaxy quest
yes were you involved in that at all
when it was being talked about
uh yes we were going to make it um
you know i i remained very good friends
with bob gordon who wrote galaxy quest
and and uh um and mark johnson who
produced it and all those actors uh
we we still are friends and talk to each
other all the time and so
um we were in the process of trying to
do
a series when alan uh
died we just we're we we couldn't
go forward after that for some you know
because we loved alan
who was the sweetest most generous
person on the planet
um and we just couldn't see it without
him um
but um you know we're still uh there's
we're still talking about it all the
time so
who knows um maybe we'll find a
different way in or something
can you before alan passed can you
share was it like really close to going
or was it one of these things just sort
of being talked about
no no we were we were we had a deal at
amazon we were meeting with amazon we
were getting notes there was a script
um and um
we had everybody on board was it one of
these things where it was going to be
like a six episode series eight episode
a made-for-movie what were you thinking
we were thinking of a ten episode
uh series that really was uh
eventually one long movie it was a
three-act structure that took ten
episodes
um and uh uh
yeah it you know and it was finding
these guys now it's even more pathetic
because it's
it's uh it's it's 15 years or 20 years
later and they're uh
um
tim tim allen's character is
lets it go that that he really went to
outer space and they've been mocked ever
since and they lost their
television series and uh they're even
more of a disaster
um it was it was a great uh opening
because they're they're
asked to go to comic-con and they think
it's because they're
they're they're going to re reinvigorate
the series but instead they're going to
hand it off to a younger group of actors
and
uh so uh
jason nessmith gets in a horrible fist
fight with um
on stage um
anyway uh and it went from there
but um i won't give away the rest in
case it somehow comes back
but it was it was fun we were laughing
about it but uh
unfortunately it didn't just didn't
happen it would have been my number one
series of that year in terms of
anticipation
i wouldn't thanks i i would have lost my
mind if that thing had
done well um listen uh believe me i have
a lot of other questions about my last
question on galaxy quest
uh what do we need to do to get the
original website back online
wait what original you mean the original
website from years ago
yeah i think there was like a galaxy
quest.com that sort of
had fun with everything it was you know
one of those 90s websites
yeah yeah i mean the studio built that
um
gosh i have no idea i didn't know i mean
i assumed it only lasted as long as they
thought they could monetize
it right um yeah they we need to talk to
someone about bringing that back
um all right i'll get on that right away